Jennifer's with us and Idaho Falls hi
Jennifer how are you good how are you
better than I deserve what's up well
I've started listening to you not too
long ago but I wanted to know what the
difference was between a 401k and a Roth
IRA my work just started offering a Roth
IRA along with the 401k you mean a Roth
401k I'm not sure I haven't they had a
401 I had a regular 401k now they're
offering the Roth 401k they can't offer
an IRA at your work only you can buy an
IRA so the Roth when it says Roth in
front of it what it means is that the
money that you're putting in there has
already been taxed its after-tax dollars
going in no tax break on the
contributions but it grows completely
tax-free which is the larger amount that
will be in your account so when you get
to 65 like 94 percent of what's in your
account will be growth it won't be what
you've put in there something does that
make sense yeah and so the fact that
it's growing tax-free is the most
important part of the equation and so
your Roth 401k just means that your
dollar when they you take money out of
your check and put it into that account
if it's Roth you'll pay taxes on the
amount you put in but then go but then
the amount goes into the account and
then it grows from that point forward
completely tax-free now does your
company have a match they do they match
up to three percent okay the match will
not be in the Roth it will be in the
traditional I know okay it'll be it'll
be sitting over there growing without
any taxes on the money going in and
without any taxes on and no taxes on the
growth until you take it out but when
you take it out the matching portion at
retirement when you take that out you
will pay taxes on that portion but it's
still a wonderful gift it's free money
so we'll take it so I do recommend the
Roth and I do recommend you to get the
Roth 401k at least up to your match
and I recommend you put it in good
growth stock mutual funds across four
types of mutual funds 25% in each of
your contribution growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and I much prefer mutual
funds that have at least a five-year
preferably a 10-year track record I try
not to buy something that's been open
one two or three years I want
something's been open for a while and I
can look at the track record and
comfortably make that decision